as well for each of you which
person's name I thought I'd hear a damn
joke about me being the mistake you
watch yourself
[Applause]
all my bad life decisions
come from being drunk you might be here
with one of yours tonight uh
I used to drink on stage
the one thing about drinking on stage is
that if they send you a shot you gotta
do it
if they don't if you don't do it it the
place goes crazy
and you would you can't get anything out
so I used to drink Jagermeister
gross and um I would do a shot and put
it down
and then no no Joe maybe two minutes
later another shot
let's do the shot put it down and I'm
not a big dude man and so I probably had
and for me there's a lot
probably six shots in about 15 minutes
debatable by the way it actually was
five because I remember the sixth
because I said to them hey
if you send another shot up here
I'm gonna throw up
and if I throw up
shows over
two seconds later I [__] shot showed
up
and I said all right everybody
let me tell you why this was amazing for
me
because I have never had the opportunity
to do this before
I did I took the shot
and I don't know if how far down it got
here maybe
Phil's here where I I projectile
vomited on the first two tables
like a stream like in the movies
like they were at a Gallagher show
and then I put the microphone on the
stand I said
I'll see you tomorrow
and I walked upstairs yeah for me booze
has always been the worst